delays in los angeles ports are leading
to a massive supply crunch experts say
this can go all the way through the
holiday season sally jeremiah spoke to
the principal of applied analysis about
what this could mean for consumers and
she joins us now live sally
brian you have probably witnessed it
everything getting delayed from
christmas trees to bikes to even
clothing and many of the people i spoke
to tell me they are trying not to panic
brian gordon principal with applied
analysis says there's been reports of
delays of cargo being able to get into
la and the long beach ports in southern
california this is creating some
potential havoc for businesses residents
consumers all throughout the southwest
portion of the u.s although this has
happened in the past there's a
confluence of events obviously a lot of
demand and activity moving a total of 50
to 90 billion worth of goods that are
sort of being held up possibly through
the month of october could extend
through the holiday season there's about
a million jobs here in southern nevada
that are dependent on their ability to
process goods and
make those sales to end consumers and
you know that puts at least some portion
of those positions potentially in
jeopardy gordon encourages everyone to
not wait for your holiday shopping and
get ahead of the game now in order to
avoid seeing what we saw last year
and out here live he also wants to
remind people that if you see some items
at your store missing you simply want to
be patient sally jaramillo live local
now